hello folks welcome to rational science
I hope you can see me okay and hear me
okay please let me know otherwise
anyways as I've been saying for the last
a couple times
um I'm on the road
I was in a little town and uh did not
have good transmission quality and so I
had to abort last Tuesday sorry about
that it's just the way things are
anyways uh let me get started with um uh
let me first listen to see if anyone can
hear me and see me okay
okay
can you hear me see me please let me
know I want to make sure that everyone's
okay
okay thank you
anyways uh I'm gonna start with
Extinction okay we had this uh gentleman
and he's a professor a college professor
has some bad news for all of us he says
the global economy apparently is going
to be in deep trouble in the coming
months okay his opinion but
um he's been credited with
um predicting previous collapses or
depressions or whatever and here he is
he says his name is nurio rubini he's
known as Dr Doom he always brings bad
news but he went from being a Cassandra
to a sage in other words Cassandra was a
lady who was able to foretell the future
but uh the the gods determined that she
would not be believed by anyone
so rubini was some kind of Cassandra now
he's considered a sage a guy who knows
what he's doing
and he says the following says Global
Financial markets should brace for a
period of decline that will be more
severe than the crashes of the 1970s and
2008.
okay central banks will eventually give
up their monetary policy tightening
before inflation is ever defeated
recession financial crisis that's what
he predicts he says stocks are down more
than 20 percent uh in places not going
to fall fast enough uh uh when you have
negative supplies Hub you get a
recession okay we're not going to get it
uh to get a fall in inflation that's
rapid enough to go to two percent okay
and the result of all this will be a
period that combines the worst of 1970s
and the global financial crisis this is
just the beginning of that pain wait
until it's real pain okay and he says
you have a major financial institution
that May Crack globally not in the U.S
maybe now but certainly internationally
okay
so uh yeah I thank the global economy is
in trouble okay the American economy is
in trouble and I think that's the main
one if if that one goes down forget
about everything else but if the U.S
economy is in trouble the global economy
is in trouble and we're all in trouble
so in that sense I agree with this
gentlemen uh thought who apparently
travels quite a bit and he says you got
to see countries firsthand you cannot
talk about just statistics you got to go
and see what's going on in each country
more or less
okay so I had some a few comments uh
regarding Extinction and the global
economy in relation to the global
economy and this is what we see is a
pretty straight up mechanism at Fox Says
crops fail globally and we're pretty
much toast okay looking at the
fertilizer crisis you know it's getting
close Okay and some of that has to do
with the fact that uh Ukraine and I
think even uh by uh
Russia
um
uh our producers of quite a bit of
fertilizer in the world and Distributors
it is more like putting in more money
and getting out no food
so it's not no money no food it is more
and more money to make sure there will
be less of everything
but more weapons
okay
and we deserve a Extinction he says
uh yeah deserve is an opinion you know
again we try to stay away from politics
and opinions but
um yeah I think we have a problem with
no money no food but not in the way he
put it here I just want people to
understand what the theory is and the
theory is not that we were we're going
to have problems with fertilizers or
that you know somehow that's going to
create a hunger out there in the world
uh I just want people to understand the
theory the theory is that money will
Disappear Completely from planet Earth
there will be no money because no one
will accept money because everybody will
see money for what it is which is an
abstraction first of all second no one
will accept it because it will be
devalued to such a point that it won't
be there won't be any point in having uh
bills or dollar bills or um
money in the bank checking account a
number in your bank account or uh
cryptocurrency or even gold
you give someone gold the guy says
that's a rock what do I do with it and
you say give it to someone else and
nobody else wants it and so not even
gold or diamonds or anything like that
will have any value I'm saying the
global economy collapses by that I mean
that money will be no more no one will
accept money because money will have no
value around the planet that's the
theory okay money will collapse okay
that's what I'm suggesting
KFL says here uh says all Empires fall
Fiat money always continues
intelligent people are thinking about
evolving past Fiat money that's becoming
more and more of a control system
okay that second paragraph there or
sentence there
um that's a political statement some
people believe that no problem
um but I'm concerned about that first
part uh whether Fiat money always
continues okay the issue is that
um and also about that other statement
Empire's fall
um yeah the United States Empire will
fall I think when money collapses I
think the United States Empire the
American Empire will be the last emperor
there won't will not be in my uh Vision
in my plan the way I see it there won't
be a Chinese Empire that replaces it the
United States will not allow China to
surpass it militarily okay we've learned
too much from history to allow that to
happen Okay so I don't think the United
States will allow that uh that's one
issue but the other one is whether Fiat
money will always continue
and the first thing you have to
understand is that uh in the Paleolithic
we had no Fiat money it was you know we
didn't trade shells even though some
people do argue for that some
paleontologists or so-called
paleontologists they say there was money
there was trading
hunter-gatherers they just killed
whatever they were going to eat fed
their families themselves that was it uh
no trading uh and as far as and so at
some point we created money of different
kinds throughout the ages and to say
that money will continue forever
uh I don't think so I think at some
point money which is the currency that
we use to trade it doesn't matter what
money you trade okay but I think money
will disappear and uh it will not be
replaced by anything because you will
not accept anything
you cannot say you're going to accept
um Brown money instead of green money
for example you know we changed the
money or the method of payment instead
of uh I don't know gold you went to
bills and for bills we went to
um cryptocurrency whatever uh you know
at some point we're going to run out of
out of ideas and the fact that we use
all these types of monies uh does not
guarantee that money itself will have no
value because uh too much debt
government's producing too much money to
cover holes and at some point in time
the system collapses and who do we go to
after that do we go to heaven and say
Hey give us more money
what for I mean you know at some point
money will have no value and people will
realize that and will not accept money
and that's why money collapses uh money
we use to pay salaries so that people
can spend that money and stimulate uh
consumption you know and it's just a
cycle and when that chain that uh
currency that we believe so uh strongly
in disappears
that whole uh system collapses complete
disintegrates so I don't think money a
Fiat money or any kind of money for that
matter will continue forever we created
it we invented it and uh we're at the
end of the line as far as you know
inventing more types of money
and so of course you're creating more
money it's just a question I'm saying
what value does money have after a while
if if you're devaluating the coin every
day and paying ever uh less real of
value to the workers which are supposed
to spend that money so that you
stimulate consumption and uh Wheels
keeps rolling that's what the issue is
so I think money will collapse we will
not believe in money we in God we will
not trust anymore right
okay another fellow says
uh it's a good theory you know the uh
money collapse right Counterpoint some
archaic species do survive sharks and
crocodiles okay he says that there's
some species did survive in the past and
so not all species are affected that's
what his argument is here humans are
classic omnivores so it would require a
systemic ecosystem collapse which seems
unlikely absent some kind of
catastrophic cosmological type event
okay a systemic global economic collapse
is certainly a possibility but that then
becomes more of an analogy rather than a
replication of what happened to the
dinosaurs
okay so let's understand the theory the
theory is that food disappeared you can
call that a ecosystem collapse but it
did not require a some kind of
catastrophic event in the sense of by
catastrophic I mean a sudden event
okay species were disappearing towards
the end of the Cretaceous towards the
end of Triassic Jurassic uh Permian
species were already disappearing way
before the end of the era or Epoch or
whatever
so it's not like they disappeared all of
a sudden at the last moment okay
for example they
um they were around for quite a while
and you can see that the number of
species were dying before the end of
Cretaceous
and a catastrophic event such as an
asteroid strike will not produce that
effect the other issue which is more
important still or more fundamental you
know more basic it's that uh you cannot
have you cannot produce with a
catastrophic event the extinction of old
species versus new species in every
single instance every single one no
exceptions okay we had the old species
die the ones that have been around for a
long period of time time the
dynasties that had been around for a
long time those were the ones that went
away and the new animals the tiny
animals that now could expand and occupy
new niches new vegetation those were the
ones that radiated that's what we see in
every mass extinction so that's what you
got to explain you don't only explain
selectivity which is one issue but also
chronological selectivity okay and you
can't do that with a uh catastrophic
event so that's that's the issue that's
the main issue against catastrophic
events you know and the most famous One
artist in the case of dinosaurs was the
um uh asteroid strike alleged asteroid
strike even if we could see that
assumption uh it doesn't tell us how
some uh
species that were around for a long time
died and while the new ones in this case
the mammals and together with the
angiosperms expanded in fact I showed
that uh last time I'm going to show it
one more time and here it is this is the
Cretaceous terrestrial Revolution okay
and you can see just by the chart that
the number of species of angiosperms
multiplied while the cycads and other
um conifers of the Cretaceous the food
that I suggest that the dinosaurs ate
were disappearing it's the angiosperms
that muscle the side all the other
plants not so much that muscle the side
the correct thing is that a way of
looking at this is that the cycads and
the conifers were already on their way
out they had run their cycle
specifically their genetic diversity
went away and it was time for them to go
okay so they were not reproducing at the
same rate as the other plants the
Andrews Burns and that's why the edges
Burns expanded who expanded with the
angiosperms the mammals which ate and
just sperms even to this day we do not
eat cycads or uh conifers we do not eat
ferns we eat and just mermaids okay any
herbivore eats angiosperm
okay another problem says
the problem with historic data it's an
unknown we don't know how many species
existed how many extinct it uh I don't
think we need to know it's not important
at all the numbers are not really that
important uh when you look at theories
but yeah you could include it in there
but it's not um
a requirement to know how many species
there were we know some species which
were extincted due to human behavior
like the thylacine and other endemic
creatures first thing you have to know
that thylacine did not die because of
man and I just pulled out one sentence
out of a paper out there it says the
size of the thylacine had become locally
extinct on both New Guinea and the
Australian Mainland before British
settlement of the continent in other
words humans did not kill the thylacine
okay uh you could say we kind of left
them without
um a garden an island you know a uh
less land for them to be in uh no the
last few thylacines they I think just
whittled away because gradually even
without man and we could have you know
we did kill one thylacine at the last
moment and this one I think was the last
one was it died in a zoo over there and
so you know we did not really kill all
the thylacines and got rid of them they
were already on their way out and you
can see or you can maybe imagine one of
the reasons for that and that is that
the thylacine was a uh marsupial
uh it's a tiger kind of like a dog like
a wolf that's got a pouch
now if that ain't a uh
old species I don't know what it is yeah
the thylacine was on its way out that's
all it was okay kangaroos who were still
around but the thylacine you know he had
uh gone through the cycle
and yeah humans uh could have uh at the
last moment muscled them aside you know
uh
kind of crowded them out but uh we were
not the uh cause of the expense of
thylacy any more than we were of other
species okay
okay so um that's my take on that uh let
me show you the last comment here Paul
says have you considered what is
referred to by scientific researchers as
the Adams event okay New Zealand tree
rings over 40 000 years old we build a
planetary magnetic pole reversal and
essentially all he talks about is that
the uh uh magnetic pole reversal uh that
the Earth turned down at you know North
Pole to South Pole and vice versa later
on uh does it supposedly every 26 000
years and so he says that is what I call
a physical mechanistic explanation for
past and future mass extinctions
the problem with that again I'm Gonna
Keep insisting uh you got to answer the
the question and the question is how do
you explain with that
uh chronological selectivity I mean even
even if the Earth turns around assuming
every 26 000 years and I don't care how
often that happens first of all that
number doesn't uh
tell you what happens after millions of
years that's one issue you would say
well if the Earth turns around on its
head uh once every 26 000 or even 50 000
years that does not explain why some of
these species did not die earlier they
would you would have new uh mass
extinctions every 50 000 years and
that's not the case that's one issue the
other issue is that even if the Earth
turns around okay so what's the
explanation so the magnetic pole is
reversed and so what uh what are we
going to say with that how did that kill
the animals and how did that kill the
animals selectively because what you got
to explain is selectivity
and more than that you gotta explain uh
chronological cell activity why do the
older animals die and the new ones
uh continue
that's what we see in the record you
don't have to take my word for it just
go out there and look at the different
epochs right uh triasse Jurassic
whatever you want to look at and you'll
see that the animals that died have been
around for longer much longer than the
ones that survived and continued on to
the next uh
pepper
that radiated with a new vegetation new
bed because vegetation also became
extinct and so you got to consider the
vegetation together with the especially
the herbivores any carnivores that
survived by you know preying on the
Carnival on the herbivores
okay okay let's move on to the subject
of today which is the Higgs okay what is
the Higgs well it's known as the God
particle and uh here's one of the the
gentlemen who I think uh baptized it as
such that God Particle okay here it is
his name is Leon Letterman and he's uh
or he was he died a couple years ago and
um he was a Nobel Prize winner
he called it the gut particle because it
was like the particle that would tell us
how mass comes into being and they were
looking for this particle for many years
and apparently the arguments that they
were successful and someone got a Nobel
Prize for doing that okay
and so the question is
um you know this God Particle uh what is
it well apparently it produces Mass it
it creates
uh the mass that subatomic particles
have okay so if they didn't have mass
before thanks to the good old
um Higgs it does have they do have mass
okay okay so here we have a gentleman
who it's named after his name is Peter
Hicks okay I also won a Nobel Prize a
couple years ago because of his
discovery
and we find that he wasn't the only guy
around uh who knew about the Higgs uh
says in the 1960s Higgs proposed a
broken symmetry in electro-week theory
could explain the origin of mass of
Elementary particles this so-called
Higgs mechanism which was proposed by
several physicists beside Higgs which
makes you kind of wonder why he got the
prize and not others right if they all
came up with the same idea predicts the
existence of a new particle the Higgs
boson the detection of which became one
of the great goals of physics therefore
the God particle some people got upset
with that name okay
and uh continue here says the Higgs
mechanism is generally accepted as an
important ingredient in the standard
model of particle physics without which
certain particles would have no Mass
Higgs first became interested in Mass
developing the idea that particles
massless when the universe began
acquired Mass a fraction of a second
later as a result of what interacting
with a theoretical field the hits field
right he's postulated this field
permeates space giving Mass to all
elementary subatomic particles that
interact with it clue arms that bind
course together confirmed most of the
particle Mass
okay so that's the general idea and uh
apparently Hayes was credited with
coming up with this Higgs field so I
guess he's one of the guys who won the
Nobel Prize because of that there were a
couple others even though there were
apparently many people around the planet
who had the idea of the Higgs already in
their heads
okay so here we have a couple guys who
explained it in uh probably more down to
earth
uh uh language so that Layman can
understand here it is okay says uh we
have these two bosons the bozos uh
certain scientists Dave Barney and Steve
Goldberg uh explain to Hicks boson okay
and they start out in their video
there's a YouTube video on these two
guys uh elementary particle particle
that has no structure
uh that didn't sound right in my ears
you know what do you mean a particle
that has no structure what does that
mean it means it has no shape
I mean you know I have no idea because
if if they say look it has no parts to
it is one thing but to say it has no
structure that also suggests or
insinuates it has no shame so that word
structure would need to be clarified
quite a bit but then they continue to
say when a particle passes through the
Higgs field it interacts and gets Mass
these are their words but all these are
their sentences their statements the
more it interacts The more mass it has
so here we have this particle that's
interacting with the Higgs field right
the more it interacts in other words the
I guess the bigger the stronger the
massive more massive or whatever you
want to call it the more it uh interacts
with the field The more mass it has okay
that's that's the general notion okay
and this is the Higgs boson is an
excitation of the Higgs field
so we have two things here we're saying
what these people are saying on the one
hand they say it's a particle that
interacts with the field then on the
other they say that it's the same field
that interacts with itself because it's
the excitation of a field
so we have it's like uh water
interacting with water in an ocean okay
we have a a wave interacting with the
ocean so to speak that's more or less
the the sense that they want to give you
and the more the wave interacts the more
uh Mass it has meaning it's going to
encounter more resistance that's that's
the essentially the notion that hicks
and all the people who believe in the
Higgs uh boson are talking about they're
saying look if if it interacts more
or it feels the field more that's gonna
have more the wave that hit the rest of
the ocean is going to have more mass
that's essentially what they're saying
and so they have the field interacting
with the field because the Higgs boson
is a vibration of the field itself
okay I hope you understood all that we
have a wave of the ocean interacting
with the ocean and the bigger the wave
the more massive it is that's
essentially it but until it interacts
until there's an interaction some
process going on some
phenomenon some motion
uh until then it has no Mass it has mass
only when it interacts
okay
and so it says by finding the Higgs
boson we know that that hicks field
exists that's how they prove the
existence of the field because if they
could find the boson they knew the field
exists because the boson has to interact
with the field
and they finally say that if there were
no Higgs field the world wouldn't exist
at all
God from the Higgs field otherwise we
wouldn't exist nobody would exist
okay
so this is more or less the notion I'll
put it up here and illustrate it we have
all these fish
and you can also consider them as waves
or whatever you want to consider them as
as
and they're swimming against the river
so they encounter resistance and I guess
the bigger the fish compared to the
smaller fish the bigger the fish the
more masked it has and uh the smaller
the fish the less Mass it has okay
and uh yeah I Illustrated it in this way
as well okay here you have the Higgs uh
masses all these Smileys they're not
smiling very much and they're moving
against the field and it's their motion
against the field that causes them to
have mass
and then allegedly this is transferred
to particles as well to other particles
as well
okay so they are the ones that
um One Way someone explained it is
assuming you were a person in a crowd
okay and you try to move through the
crowd
kind of the bigger you are the more you
vibrate or whatever uh you encounter
more resistance because you hit more
people in the crowd whereas if you're
skinny and you don't move as much you
don't vibrate as much well then you have
an easier time to go through the field
of people
so that's more or less the notion
but there's a little bit of problem
that's what I want you to think about
okay if it's true that Mass
is a function of an interaction between
the boson and the field right and that's
what conveys Mass to other particles
assuming even to the uh pigs itself
then mass is a dynamic process
okay let me repeat that what what these
people are saying is that there has to
be an interaction the Higgs boson has to
interact with the field and we're going
to forget the notion that the field that
the H boson is something different than
the field okay or or similar to a viewer
it's the field itself but let's forget
about that let's assume it's a particle
so this particle is like something
separate discrete all on its own it's
going to interact with the field and the
more it interacts the more it vibrates
the bigger it is any way you want to
conceptualize that
that interaction is what conveys Mass
to itself into other particles
okay so it's got to be an interaction
there's got to be a verb end or a
dynamic motion
without that you have no Mass
and that notion kind of contrasts with
what you'll see next okay and it is what
is mass
so let's start there let's find out what
mass is what we what this particle of
mass is uh simulating you know what what
concept what what thingy is this Mass
okay that's what we're trying to get to
okay so we look it up and go to the
Wikipedia good source uh because a lot
of people who write in there and that's
the one everybody anyways uh consults
most people out there so that's the
notion that the lay men have out there
and of course if the scientists or
physicists or mathematical physicists
would object to that they would have
changed that anything that's wrong in
the Wikipedia anyways okay and so here
it is you go to Wikipedia says in the
physical science okay in physical
science one may distinguish conceptually
between at least seven different aspects
of mass or seven physical Notions that
involve the concept of mass
they have you could say seven different
definitions of mass they don't have one
definition that we can sink our teeth
into they have many okay several okay
that's not a good starting point
uh so what is mass well you look it up
in a couple other sources uh respectable
you know always respectable
and you finance uh here's a Northwestern
University says Mass how much matter
there is in something
well how much matter how many atoms how
many particles any way you want to look
at it that's different than what we just
heard from these other people saying
that mass is an interaction between the
wave and the ocean the particle in the
ocean
anyway you want to see that as well okay
uh we had two different Notions of what
mass is is mass the quantity of
particles of units departed to a balls
of grains of sand or is it an
interaction between the grain of sand
and something else the field
those are two different Notions
you know they don't match these two
Notions these two definitions and again
uh the Eric Weinstein's world of physics
and another prominent site says the
quantity of matter contained in an
object that's what mass is well quantity
of matter is very different than
interaction
quantity of matter is I have 12 marbles
in my bag that's a quantity of matter
and that's different than saying that
the marble you know hits against
something and produces
the so-called Mass concept
okay
and just in case we go to find out what
weight is why because weight is an
interaction
okay and apparently according to
mathematical physics and here you see it
several definitions exist for weight
yeah many definitions for Mass many
definitions for weight not all of which
are equivalent obviously we have seven
different uh or several definitions of
weight obviously they cannot be
equivalent and it says their weight of
an object the force it exerts on its
support so for example you have there a
scale you put a ball on in it's going to
push the scale downwards that we call
that the weight okay whenever it stops
and uh so that's the weight it's an
interaction weight in that sense is an
interaction
and that's different than quantity of
matter than saying I'm going to put 10
balls on on the scale
or no scale at all just 10 balls 10
balls being Mass
you know how much mass the 10 balls have
together well it's a 10 Ball Match
that's what it is here this is different
this is how much uh one ball pushes on a
scale an interaction those two are two
different Notions completely different
so I guess when they talk about the
Higgs they're talking about weight and
not about Mass because they're saying
that the ball is going to interact with
the field
right and that's going to be the result
the result of that will be Mass that's
called weight not mass okay we're
talking about weight
mass is something else masses quantity
of atoms in the ocean that would be Mass
but weight is the interaction of one
ball or particle or whatever with the
ocean if the interaction is weight and
here there's suggesting that what the
Higgs is is not the particle of mass
seems like it's the particle of weight
okay
and um
there we have it there's a physics fact
just in case confirmation weight is
independent of the object state of
motion
now we have a contradiction because
right now they said it's an interaction
now they say it's the uh and you have to
have something moving and now they say
no you don't have to have anything
moving and doesn't consider any contact
force
and that's because they never saw the uh
or or felt the mediator of gravity of
mass right of whatever confers Mass upon
a particle that's why they say there's
no contact we say there is contact the
contact is through the electromagnetic
rope so they are in contact we just
can't see or touch that mediator that's
different than saying there is no
physical contact okay if it says when
the particle Photon right
is at rest its relativistic mass has a
minimum value called the rest Mass which
in the case of the photon is known as
zero the mass of the photon is
considered to be zero okay so as long as
it doesn't move whatever that is because
uh the photon is always moving allegedly
the light never stops uh then it's got
rust Mass but as the particle the photon
right is accelerated to ever higher
speeds it's relativistic mass increases
without limit
well we got a little problem because now
they're not talking about interaction
they're just saying speed
they're just saying the particle is
moving away from something through I
guess empty space it's not interacting
with anything it's just going faster
faster and faster the faster it goes it
has more weight
in fact more mass they say which is what
quantity of particles
so I guess the photon is acquiring more
particles as it moves along or is it
that it's pressing harder on the scale
that's going to measure it
what is mass what is weight what is the
difference between mass and weight these
people keep going around in circles they
say that mass in the case of the uh
Higgs right mass is an interaction
then they say no uh weight is an
interaction the ball with a scale now
they're saying there has to be no
interaction with for weight it all the
the particle just has to travel faster
meaning it if if there was a scale there
you could uh gauge you know how much
pressure it causes
and without that you know they just say
the faster it goes the more it weighs no
interaction whatsoever necessary for
that to happen which has nothing at all
to do with the quantity of matter which
is the definition of mass
so we went full circle around we don't
know if we're talking about weight or
mass whether the Higgs is a particle of
weight or of mass and we will never know
because they've never defined mass or
weight they have seven or definitions
for Mass I don't know how many they have
for weight
so we have no idea whatsoever at all
what these people are doing out there
and just in case you know we throw the
icing on the cake here it is uh these
are wheeler and Taylor uh two so-called
physicists mathematical physicists and
they clarify for us everything that you
ever needed to know okay here it is they
say nature does not offer us any concept
as the amount of matter
Mass right history has struck down every
proposal to Define such a term even if
we could count number of atoms or by any
other counting method try to evaluate
amount of matter that number would not
equal Mass
okay so after all this said it done we
have no idea what mass is what weight is
uh or whether the Higgs is a particle of
mass or a weight
what is the Higgs it interacts with the
field I thought that was weight when
something interacts or pushes against
something against the scale
and they're saying in Mass alleged these
quantity of matter
and now they're saying uh no uh masses
actually not quantity of matter it's an
interaction
okay so we're not talking about how many
atoms we're saying how much one atom uh
interacts with a field of some kind
of a notion or whatever some fluid I
guess
so we have a contradiction there they
have not decided what mass is or whether
this Higgs is a particle of mass or a
weight
here is that we look it up in the
standard model of quantum mechanics okay
and we find the Higgs and so if you ever
wanted to know what what the Higgs looks
like well it looks like apparently you
know for what I can see there it looks
like a ball that's got an H on it you
like Harvard you know an H
and that's the Higgs it's got all these
little numbers there we don't care about
we just want to know what it looks like
and I guess it looks like that like a
ball with an H on it and it has so it's
a ball that has no Mass until it
interacts
which means uh it's the
particle of weight
I don't you tell me
okay that's it for the Higgs
let's move on to our science critic he
made a video 45 minute video criticizing
the scientific method unbelievable and
today he's going to talk about what he
accuses me of doing and that is uh using
word salad known as semantics he says
I'm challenging the scientific uh
establishment using semantics
whatever that is okay so let's listen to
him so we know what the subject matter
is today what he what his argument is
here he goes give me a second and here
goes
the issue I address in this rebuttal is
this fellow apparently believes that
defining word scientifically amounts to
Petty semantics
you know and Bill's efforts to use
semantics to try and undermine current
science he should really read the
definitions a bit better now if I had to
guess it's probably because he wants to
say that modern science is irrational
look how irrational it is look at the
definition of an object
okay so these are the concerns and these
are the questions I put before you for
you to ponder you uh you know chew on
them see what you come up with these are
my criticism of his criticism okay here
it is does a scientist need to Define
terms in order to communicate a theory
you know if I start saying XYZ and I
don't Define XYZ do you think you'll
understand my theory or do I need to
clarify what x y z mean if I'm going to
use those words in some kind of
dissertation
okay so that's the first question second
issue if you challenge a definition that
makes us that makes or breaks the
speaker's Theory right are you engaging
in Petty semantics
okay yeah so if you challenge someone
say look you know what do you mean by
God for example what do you mean by
space time
what do you mean by black hole
is that uh and and even if the guy tells
you what it is and you challenge that
definition because you say it's an
irrational definition and at least you
you challenge what he's saying his his
notion of it
um is that just uh just Petty semantics
or is it getting the foundations of
physics straight
okay that's the issue before you
third issue if the presenter treats the
concept mass as a physical object for
example right and begins to move it
around during his dissertation right
right is pointing this out to him a
semantic argument
okay so here here's uh some people like
we just saw
um using the word mass
and they say mass is an interaction
you say well hold it what do you mean
mass is an interaction when these other
your colleagues here you know or the
dictionary or whoever defines us the
quantity of matter
and now you're saying it's not the
quantity of matter it's the interaction
of matter with something else
well those are two different Notions I
need those clarified I need those you
know uh organized in some way that I can
follow your presentation
is uh pointing that out to him a
semantic argument saying oh this is just
Petty semantic word salad
word Wizardry
or is it goes to the root of what he's
trying to uh
theorize for you
right and the last issue is the
definition of the synagoguanon word
object remember this is the this is what
was at the root of his complaint right
used by mathematicians when they provide
physical interpretations the main one
being C and touch because they Define it
as many uh that which has matter or is
made of matter or whatever but that's
not the one they use the one they use is
C touch because they're going to go to a
lab and they want to see and touch
whatever they consider to be an object a
thing right and if that's the one they
use is it
um if if it's unscientific if it's
irrational meaning that uh for example
you need two objects to be able to
produce touch uh you cannot see an
object that's on the other side of the
universe uh
you don't see one on the other side of
the Earth let alone on the other side of
the universe so not all objects can be
seen not all other objects can be
touched but she knows that you imagine
so if you imagine a tree or a rock uh is
the word Rock
an object is the word tree an object
even though you can't see or touch the
one I'm thinking of
so if it's an irrational or pointing
that out to
the person who's giving the presentation
is that a semantic argument a petty
semantic argument
so these are the questions that you
should think about okay and all I can do
is uh Point them out to you so that you
Ponder them on your own I'm going to
tell you what to think I'm just telling
you what the questions that pop in my
mind
okay
okay let's move on to the questions and
comments people made since last time uh
had a lot of them so I'm just gonna
throw gonna go through a few of them
okay here we go the first one says what
are your thoughts on Timothy Morton's
hyper objects some weird physics
philosophy concept well I looked him up
I didn't know who he was so I looked him
up Martin uses the turn to explain
objects so massively distributed in time
and space as to transcend localization
such as climate change and styrofoam
okay uh not very physical I think he was
dealing more with politics
can you continue his uh this is out of
the Wikipedia by the way uh Morton's
theoretical writings include the
cultural significance and context of
food ecology and environmentalism and
object oriented ontology
in metaphysics object-oriented ontology
triple o right is a 21st century school
of thought that rejects the privileging
of human existence over the existence of
non-human objects object-oriented
ontology maintains that objects exist
independently of human perception
perception much like uh we covered in
the past tantian numina okay so this is
uh what this uh fellow Morton Timothy
Morton uh proposes uh they call them
philosophers I think that has nothing to
do with philosophy or physics or science
or nothing it's just politics that's all
it is they create Concepts that have
nothing to do with anything and they
call it what object-oriented
whatever ontology
and here it is so we look it up what is
a hyper object well these are some
characteristics okay five of them uh
it's viscous it's molten not local phase
and inter-objective
uh first one hyper objective hyperoptics
idea to any other object they touch okay
great hyper objects are so massive that
they refute the idea that space-time is
fixed concrete or consistent now local
hyper Optics are massively distributed
distributed in time and space to the
extent that their totality cannot be
realized in any particular local
manifestation phase hyper Optics occupy
a higher dimensional space whatever that
is right then other entities can
normally perceive
and it says continues hyperopsis would
appear differently if an observer could
have a higher multi multi-dimensional
view
and the last one inner objective uh
hyper objects are formed by relations
between more than one object in other
words he's not talking about physics
what we're talking about here are just
uh Concepts that this fellow created I
guess because they ran out of topics to
deal with and so they create these new
Concepts
you know you have the mathematicians
they create the mathematical objects and
these people created the what object
oriented uh ontology
meaning what exists out there
it's got nothing to do with anything
and the second thing is that just keep
in mind that physics is the science of
existence only physics deals with
existence it has a monopoly over that
anyone touching the word exist or
talking about what exists out there you
know ontology maybe philosophy or some
call it it crossed the line into physics
okay whether he knows it or not
okay another fellow talks about uh see
touch here says a material thing that
can be seen or touched okay that's the
notion we have out there or the
mathematicians have out there of what an
object is see or touch and he gives an
example he says if you see a laser beam
is that material
and the answer he says is no okay
because
um he says you can't touch it or see it
he's right about that to some degree we
can't really touch it but what he may
not be aware of is that light is if it's
like we propose a rope that's the
Assumption we made and it's connected to
every atom you know in his finger every
rope is connected to every atom in his
finger then you are touching in a sense
um a light okay you just don't see her
feel it but you are touching it whether
you know it or not because it's not like
too
separate things touching it's like one
becomes the other
it's like you know in that sense it's
continuous so in that sense you could
say it's not touching but there is a
connection there but otherwise he's
right you know it's uh you can't uh base
what an object is on the basis of these
two criteria see and touch
and
here's the next one fellow says
uh prove a God and a devil it does not
need to be combined with science
in science especially in physics we do
not prove anything specifically the
existence of anything we don't prove the
existence of a table we do not prove the
existence of God or of the devil or deny
the existence of God or the devil okay
this is not a question of opinion or a
belief it's a question of let's define
the word exist
so we do not prove what we do merely is
uh Define the word exist and there you
have it exist physical presence uh
physical refers to an object and
presence refers to location
an object that exists is one and only
obvious Concepts cannot exist uh or be
said to exist not in science not in
physics right which holds a monopoly
over the word exists okay or
a rational discussions
um to be an object is not sufficient it
must have location once it has location
you know distance between it and other
objects then we can say it exists by
definition so it's not a question of
belief it's a question of defining the
word exist so that we can use it
consistently meaning scientifically
okay so yeah
if God or the double
um one exists first they need to be
objects they need to be things and as
long as you treat uh both God or the
devil and or the devil right as things
you you started on the right foot and
the next one is they have to have
location and if they do have location
they both Exist by definition pursuant
to the definition
okay here's another file you put a
comment here and he says I think gravity
is confusing because it is two separate
scenarios okay there is the tension
version a and then there is the pull
version B okay we have pull versus
tension tension is a static concept as
we've discussed in the past okay no one
wins the tug of wars uh War uh pool does
pull someone has to win the tug of war
that's why pulled is a force tension is
not a force except in mathematical
physics okay Ebola on the table is an
under tension but not being pulled
okay
um well it is under tension no doubt
about it because it's not assuming it
doesn't move a bit it does have weight
there is gravity what we call gravity uh
acting upon it and what we say it's
being pulled which is the wrong word in
that sense he's right it's just being
held there by the ropes that are
connecting every one of its atoms to
here on Earth with the our planet okay
that's the issue okay no problem but
then he says that remove the table now
the ball gets pulled down to the floor
while still being under tension
uh the answer is no it doesn't get
pulled down okay that's why gravity is
not a pull Force if we come down to you
know to the nitty-gritty to to really
understand what gravity is we are saying
that as the ball Falls
it has different weight at different
locations uh more weight the closer it
gets to the object in this case the
Earth
what's happening is all the ropes fan
out there are more independent ropes
acting upon every one of the atoms that
form the ball and that's why the ball
falls down it's not being pulled
we have to forget the word pull we use
it quite a bit I use it too I want you
to know that but uh when you put me
against the ropes again against the wall
okay uh I will clarify that there is no
pull what's happening is more and more
independent ropes that were before on
the same axis now are acting on separate
axis that's what it is okay and so he
says maybe it would be useful to give
them different labels rather than
calling them both gravity for example
gravity for a and gravitational
attraction for B well yeah that's a
question of uh wording all I'm saying is
we should forget the word pull for
Gravity we have this notion that gravity
is a pull Force there is no Force there
is no pull what it is is the object at
different locations closer to the Earth
has greater and greater weight because
the uh ropes fan out all the ropes that
connect every atom of that object to
every atom of the earth they all fan out
and act
at different angles that's what it is
okay and close the closer you get the
ball gets to the Earth the more ropes
that fan out
okay here we have another one uh there
is definite reason for Gravity well
hopefully there has to be in that reason
the word is cause there's a definite
cause reason we use for philosophy I am
convinced that I know okay I am
convinced yeah he Pats himself on the
back I'm too missed I know okay that
gravity is caused by push factor
okay he's gonna he's one of those people
who proposes push gravity and he's not
the only one there's a lot of people out
there that think gravity is a push Force
okay there is reality in Shadow theories
of gravity okay and that's the the sage
type mechanism where it goes all the way
to lucretius by the way and that is that
people think that uh gravity is a
function of um this shadowing that if if
you put something in front of something
else it creates a shadow effect and
because
the object that is moving is protected
by this other one and then it has it it
it it'd be it's being pulled or pushed
at a stronger a stronger with a stronger
Force and the issue there is no uh
there's no Shield that you can put for
any object in the universe that you can
create that is a like a gravity Shield
if an astronaut has some kind of shield
in front of them the gravity for some
reason goes right through the shield and
put pulls and we'll use the word pull
both on the astronaut and The Shield at
the same time
so you cannot put a shield in front of
you to protect yourself from Gravity
okay so yeah like I say gravity is a
function of not a pull Force what it is
is the object has more weight at when
the distance between the object and what
is Falling Towards uh decreases
okay here's um another file along the
same line Looks like we have a gravity
day today
uh there is a mechanism for push gravity
okay you just use pressure of all of the
objects to push out and contract space
around all of the objects locally
okay we're not gonna get involved into
all the details I just wanted to uh
address the fact that he says contract
space
is nothing that which doesn't have shape
it's a concept space is not a thing okay
space is none thing okay it's nothing
you can't contract nothing you cannot
contract physically contract that which
is not an object that which is a concept
so that's how we need to uh to address
in what he raised there so uh yeah as
long as you can change that maybe we can
talk about your push force or whatever
you think it is you know gravity is
and another phone looks he says uh the
smallest bioball measurement of time is
derived from the unit of distance called
the Planck length Okay it is impossible
using the known laws of quantum
mechanics and a known behavior of
gravity to determine a position to a
precision
smaller than the blank length
well I don't know I can conceptualize
something small I mean you know count to
ten and uh think of a number less than
that okay you can see name any number
you want you can say hello 55 I'll say
54 and I beat you and any number you
want to think about I'll I can think of
a lower number
okay you just tell me what your number
is and I'll beat you every day of the
year okay and uh so the same with length
just give me the blank length I'll
divide it in half and I already beat you
because I can imagine something smaller
than the plank length I don't have to
measure it I only have to conceptualize
it okay
and he said there's no way to go below
the plank of the scale in terms of
distance or time yes it is I just have
put it divided in half divide the blank
length thing half and you'll be okay
you'll find out that you can get as low
as you want divide blank length by a
million you'll get even smaller pieces
of plank lengths okay now whether
they're out there or not it doesn't
matter and what matters is that I can
conceptualize something smaller than the
blank leg
it's where Dimensions become so tiny
that the classical laws of physics break
down in Quantum effects kick in
okay yeah again
um we don't care about any of that none
of that has anything to do with physics
okay it's got to do with math and once
again I can conceptualize anything
smaller than the plank length just give
me the plank length to or give it to
Adam man and he'll cut it in half and
give you half a plank leg
okay
and finally we got the last uh follow
here it talks about motion he says I
have trouble accepting the idea that
motion is eternal in the way it was
discussed here with existence I followed
the logic in that if it's not Eternal we
are stuck with creation ex nearly okay
yeah I mean you can have creation
um
if it's not Eternal it had better be
created
okay but he has a different
um version of what motion is or how
motion started he says however I don't
see emotion as having the same problem
if we can let go of the notion of a
primary mover
well yeah I mean that that's the issue
the issue is that you cannot let go of a
primary mover because you need something
to move whatever you're gonna move for
the first time
and that means that wasn't the first
thing to move you now have to revert to
the primary mover and find out how it
started moving
you know uh all these uh like Augustine
and uh Saint Anselm and all these
thoughts in the old days you know they
were talking about the primary mover
meaning God
and so they they just suggested that God
set everything in motion not only did he
create the first objects other than him
if God is a hymn he created objects
under the other than him for the first
time and then he set them in motion he's
the primary mover
or the prime mover and so the question
is yeah well you can't do without the
prime mover for motion for the origin of
motion anymore that you cannot imagine
the uh the popping into existence
of an object all by itself you know I
think we all have to agree that we would
need a God to do that a magician of some
kind and then the question is you know
is he Eternal or how did he come into be
okay so we have to explain the God as
well his how he came into being how he
began to move
okay and so if you get rid of God well
it's I think it gets worse for the
people who propose uh creationism
mathematical physicist general
relativity quantum mechanics also
because they talk about particles coming
in from the void and if you're gonna
postulate that and say look the particle
came into being it started moving for
the first time all by itself well you
know I think most people would say well
I'd rather have God and just have him
wave the magic wand and put it in put it
into existence and into motion right
then we can all deal with that a little
more then we can fight about God later
on but at least we know that we can
understand how the particle came into
being and how it started to move we need
that prime mover Prime Creator as well
so yeah he wants to get rid of the prime
mover he says let's assume there is no
prime mover well yeah I mean that's that
is the whole issue so he didn't really
conceptualize anything he said he had
trouble accepting the idea of Eternal
motion and yeah in the case of the Rope
model we say that uh motion has always
been there or as everything has always
been moving let's put it that way and at
the same time always had every object
out there always existed why because you
cannot have space spontaneously acquire
length width and height and turn into
something and vice versa you cannot have
something that has length width and
height a three-dimensional object lose
its Dimensions suddenly and turn into
absolute nothing empty space
so unless you can tell us what the
mechanism is
uh you cannot say well I don't know how
that happened but that it did happen
that's what I believe in well you're
irrational that's all you can say okay
because if you cannot explain the
mechanism you cannot say that you're
gonna believe in that simply because you
want to you can take that into you into
your church talk about it over there but
not into science not into physics
okay folks with that I hope to see you
next Sunday okay and hopefully I'll be
back in Frankfurt by then I'll stop by
rambling and my uh right